die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend den
Sport gibt's von Sven Voss guten Abend
und das sind die großen Themen heute
Distanz zur Demokratie wächst immer mehr
Menschen in Deutschland haben
rechtsextreme Einstellungen zeigt eine
Studie
Hilferuf aus der Landwirtschaft
Tierhalter fordern mehr finanzielle
Unterstützung um ihre Tiere artgerechte
halten zu können
und gut gekämpft und doch verloren im
ersten Champions League Spiel der
Vereinsgeschichte unterliegt Union
Berlin erst in der Nachspielzeit Real
Madrid
es ist alarmierend die Zahl der
deutschen die einen rechtsextremes und
Demokratie feindliches Weltbild haben
ist gestiegen immer mehr Menschen auch
aus der gesellschaftlichen Mitte haben
das Vertrauen in staatliche
Institutionen verloren das zeigt eine
neue Studie der Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung
schauen wir uns die Ergebnisse genauer
an
hatten bisher zwei bis drei Prozent der
Bevölkerung einen gefestigtes
rechtsextremes Weltbild so ist dieser
Anteil sprunghaft angestiegen auf jetzt
8%. den Indikatoren dabei unter anderem
Fremdenfeindlichkeit
Antisemitismus Befürwortung einer
Diktatur deutlich ist der regionale
Unterschied sechs Prozent der im Westen
aufgewachsenen Menschen teilen laut
Studie rechtsextreme Einstellungen in
Ostdeutschland sind es 16 Prozent Bern
Benthin hat die Hintergründe
das Rechtsextremismus stärker in die
Gesellschaft einsickert beobachten Sie
hier schon seit langem die Initiative
Gesicht zeigen berät klärt auf versucht
zu verhindern und schaut besorgt auf das
momentane Abdriften ins Extreme
bei Gesicht zeigen spüren natürlich sehr
deutlich von den Rückmeldungen die wir
bekommen dass es viel mehr hassmeldungen
gibt dass es viel mehr
Bedrohungssituationen gibt dass viele
Leute die sich vor Ort engagieren also
in den ländlichen Gebieten auch jetzt
nicht mitten in der Großstadt dass die
bedroht werden dass sie sich
zurückziehen nur jeder zweite vertraut
den staatlichen Institution 8% Teilen
rechtsextreme Einstellungen zu diesen
Ergebnissen kommt die aktuelle
mittelstudie im Auftrag der
Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung
was unsere Daten zeigen ich glaube sie
zeigen dass die Mitte sich tatsächlich
in Teilen auf Distanz zu Demokratie
begeben hat in Teilen hat sie sich
radikalisiert was Deutschland jetzt
braucht ist eine einzige starke Partei
die die Volksgemeinschaft insgesamt
verkörpert überwiegend oder voll und
ganz stimmen dem
23,9 Prozent der Befragten zu die
Bundesrepublik ist durch die vielen
Ausländer in einem gefährlichen Maß über
fremdet dem Stimmen 27,8 Prozent
überwiegend oder voll zu auch
antidemokratische Einstellungen nehmen
zu Ablehnung gegen Parteien und Politik
die regierenden Parteien betrügen das
Volk das Sagen 29,7%
. einige Politiker haben es verdient
wenn die Wut gegen Sie schon einmal in
schon mal in Gewalt umschlägt nur als
Beispiel dem Stimmen 13 Prozent zu wir
erleben auf kommunaler Ebene das leider
Gottes die Zahl der Bedrohungen
Beleidigung bis hin zu tätlichen
Übergriffen gegenüber Bürgermeisterin
Bürgermeister aber auch gegen
Mitarbeitenden in den Verwaltungen in
den vergangenen Jahren deutlich
zugenommen hat und das ist eine
besorgniserregende Entwicklung insofern
besteht dass die Ergebnisse der Studie
auch nach den Gründen für diese Zahlen
sucht die Studie verantwortlich sei die
Vielzahl an Krisen aber auch ein
Grundgefühl der Einsamkeit in einer
zunehmend zersplitterten Gesellschaft
vertiefen wir das weiter mit Theo call
Theo wieso lehnen immer mehr Deutsche
die Demokratie ab
ja es gibt dem wahren Wortsinn auch ganz
leise Gründe die bisher wenig beachtet
wurden das nämlich immer mehr Menschen
zu Hause einsam und persönlich
verunsichert sind und wer isoliert und
ohne gesellschaftliche Bindung ist der
sei so die Forscher weniger krisenfest
und neige eher zu menschenfeindlichen
und antidemokratischen Haltung daneben
aber gibt es natürlich auch die vielen
augenfälligeren Ursachen also die sich
auf türmenden Krisen sind für viele
Menschen eine soziale und
wirtschaftliche Bedrohung also
corona-pandemie Krieg in der Ukraine
Inflation bedroht da Wohlstand und
massive Zuwanderung ein wachsender Teil
der gesellschaftlichen Mitte reagiert
auf diese Weltlage nervös bis aggressiv
und fordert einfach und autoritäre
Lösungen und die haben dann mit
Demokratie nichts mehr zu tun die
Forscher sprechen jetzt wörtlich von
einem Kipppunkt es sei höchste Zeit zu
handeln vielen Dank für diese Einordnung
und den Link zur kompletten
Rechtsextremismus Studie finden Sie bei
uns in unserer ZDF heute App dort auch
ein Interview mit einer Mitautorin
Polen ist seit Beginn des russischen
Angriffskrieges einer der größten
Unterstützer der Ukraine
zuletzt ist der Ton zwischen den beiden
Ländern jedoch rauer geworden jetzt hat
Polen angekündigt dass die Ukraine nur
noch bereits vereinbarte
Waffenlieferungen bekommen werde darüber
hinaus aber keine mehr stattdessen will
Polen die eigenen waffenbestände
auffüllen in Polen herrscht derzeit
Wahlkampf Natalie Steger berichtet
was der polnische Ministerpräsident
davon sich gibt gestern Abend sorgt
international für Aufsehen
wir liefern keine Waffen mehr an die
Ukraine weil wir uns jetzt selbst mit
den modernsten waffenausstatten werden
das Verhältnis Warschau Kiew ist
belastet wegen des Streits um
Getreidelieferungen aus der Ukraine in
die EU polen will die heimischen Bauern
davor schützen denn es ist Wahlkampf die
peace Fisch zunehmend am noch rechteren
Rand die peace konkurriert gerade mit
der parteikonfader Ratia um skeptischere
Wähler die negativ gegenüber der Ukraine
eingestellt sind die
Opposition empört über die Waffen
Debatte
der Ukraine politische Messer in den
Rücken zu stechen wären sie schlachten
an der Front aus trägt ist ein
moralischer und geopolitischer Skandal
nur weil es sich für die peace
wahlkampftechnisch auszahlen soll die
[Applaus]
Opposition wittert ihre Chance laut
Umfragen reicht es für die peace bei den
Wahlen am 15 Oktober nicht mehr für die
absolute Mehrheit
in Warschau gilt es als offenes
Geheimnis das Polen das sehr viele
Waffen an die Ukraine geliefert hat nun
die die es noch hat für die eigene
Verteidigung braucht
moraviewski im Wahlkampf und er nimmt in
Kauf was seine Worte international
auslösen
das Kalkül der Nationalkonservativen
Polen first und sei es auch auf Kosten
des Verhältnisses zu Kiew
[Musik]
das ukrainische Militär meldet heute
Angriffe auf die von Russland
annektierte Halbinsel Krim dabei soll
der russische Luftwaffenstützpunkt Saki
beschädigt worden sein in der Ukraine
gab es auch wieder mehrere russische
Raketenangriffe unter anderem auf die
Hauptstadt Kiel dabei soll es insgesamt
zwei Tote und mindestens 18 Verletzte
gegeben haben auch Teile der Wasser und
Stromversorgung waren vorübergehend
unterbrochen
seit mehr als eineinhalb Jahren herrscht
dort inzwischen Krieg und besonders
trifft er die Kinder in dem Land wir
schauen heute am Weltfriedenstag der
Vereinten Nationen auf eine Kindheit im
Krieg Alissa jung hat dafür in Kiew mit
ukrainischen Schülerinnen und Schülern
gesprochen
vier Kinder der 3b dieser Schule in Kiew
fehlen heute im Unterricht die Eltern
haben sie zu Hause gelassen denn die
Nacht war kurz die Hauptstadt wurde
erneut Ziel eines Luftangriffs
Mama hat uns geweckt und uns einen
Schlafplatz im Bad aufgebaut und als wir
dann im Bad waren flogen die Raketen
über unser Haus
Angriffe auf das ganze Land am Tag des
internationalen Friedens Daria aus der
siebenb fällt es schwer die Erlebnisse
zu verarbeiten ich kann mich nicht mehr
an Frieden erinnern das Gute wird aus
dem Kopf verdrängt man erinnert sich
eher an das Schlechte
Zlata schläft fast jede zweite Nacht im
Bad dass ein sicherer Ort ohne Fenster
ist und Kira muss bei Luftalarm nachts
in einem städtischen bunkerschutz suchen
irgendwo auf der Welt wir erleben das 24
Stunden 7 Tage die Woche doch trotzdem
viele Lehrerin und Lena lewtschenko das
heute Platz für Zukunftsträume ist
Frieden ist Freiheit Glück und ein
friedlicher Himmel
wenn kein Krieg ist und keine Soldaten
sterben
wenn die Kinder lachen können
wir brauchen einen friedlichen Himmel
dazu tanzen sie heute
für Frieden in der Ukraine
[Musik]
einen Tag nach dem Ende der Kämpfe in
der Kaukasusregion Bergkarabach strebt
Aserbaidschan nach der vollständigen
Kontrolle über das Gebet Vertreter
Aserbaidschans trafen sich zu Gesprächen
mit dem militärisch unterlegenen
Armenien in bergkambach über die Zukunft
der Region gestern hatten sich beide
Seiten auf eine Waffenruhe geeinigt
inzwischen laufen auch
Evakuierungsmaßnahmen tausende
Zivilistinnen und Zivilisten seinen
Sicherheit gebracht worden
völkerrechtlich zu Aserbaidschan wird
aber mehrheitlich von Armenien bewohnt
Bundespräsident Steinmeier und italiens-
die Tragödie können auch als ein Weckruf
dienen vor eineinhalb Wochen waren in
den Bürgerkriegsland bei massiven
Überschwemmungen tausende Menschen ums
Leben gekommen
immer mehr Flüchtlinge kommen aktuell
über das Mittelmeer nicht nur das
italienische Lampedusa ist davon gerade
betroffen sondern auch die griechischen
Inseln die Zahl der Menschen die per
Boot dort ankommen ist derzeit knapp
viermal so hoch wie im vergangenen Jahr
alleine im August waren es fast 5.600
Flüchtlinge die allermeisten landen auf
den Inseln nahe der türkischen Küste
Andreas poste mit dem Beispiel Samos
die griechische Küstenwache nimmt sie
auf vor Samos in der OST agilis nur 1,6
km sind es von der türkischen Küste bis
hierher allein in den vergangenen 24
Stunden haben so über 100 Menschen in
boten die Europäische Union erreicht mit
dem ersten von zehn neuen Aufnahme Camps
finanziert von der EU sollte auf Samos
alles besser werden und das ist es auch
aber und das ist das große kritische
aber der Menschenrechtsorganisationen
die Camps seinen aktuell mit der Anzahl
der Migranten überfordert
wieder länger wir sprechen nicht von
Monaten aber wir sprechen sicherlich von
einigen Wochen in einen Menschen die
Asyl beantragen sich in einem Zustand
der defacto Inhaftierung befinden
es gebe zu wenig Personal zur
Bearbeitung der Asylanträge und zur
medizinischen Versorgung außerdem würden
Neuankömmlinge wegen des Platzmangels
auch in der abschiebehaftanstalt
untergebracht was einer
Freiheitsberaubung gleichkomme die
Belastungsgrenze sei laut griechische
migrationsministerium erreicht besonders
mit der Rückführung abgelehnte
Asylbewerber gäbe es große Probleme da
das Abkommen mit der Türkei auf Eis
liegt
und hier steht damit das internationale
System zum Schutz von geflüchteten
funktionieren kann müssen auch
diejenigen die abgelehnt werden
rückgeführt werden und das ist heute
leider nicht möglich europa muss hier
gemeinsam Druck ausüben denn nur
gemeinsam kann es effektiv sein
wichtiges Signal der Annäherung mit der
Türkei am Rande der
UN-Generalversammlung Griechenlands
Ministerpräsident mit zur Tages und der
türkische Präsident Erdogan sein
übereingekommen sich gemeinsam mit der
Migrationsfrage zu befassen weitere
Gespräche sind vereinbart
zurück nach Deutschland diese Kühe hier
haben Platz und Auslauf ideale
tierhaltungsbedingungen auch für
Schweine oder Hühner das wünschen sich
viele die Fleisch essen und das sind
auch Forderungen aus der Politik aber
mehr Tierwohl bedeutet für die
Bäuerinnen und Bauern auch mehr kosten
deshalb fordern sie von der
Agrarministerkonferenz in Kiel mehr
Unterstützung wie Henriette de Maizière
berichtet
für Bauer Dietrich pritschau ist die
Schweinezucht ein ständiger Balanceakt
zwischen dem was für die Tiere gut ist
und dem was die Verbraucher bereit sind
fürs Fleisch zu zahlen wir kämpfen in
der Nutztierhaltung wirklich auch um die
Akzeptanz der Verbraucher und auch um
die Akzeptanz der Tierschützer der
Familienbetrieb in Schleswig-Holstein
hat 430 Muttersauen in den Stall darf
nur der Schweinezüchter
Hygienevorschriften Schweinehaltung und
wie sie künftig aussehen soll ein
Dauerstreit Thema klar ist Tierwohl hat
seinen Preis tierisch Produkte können in
dem jetzigen Preisniveau nicht artgemäß
umgesetzt werden da wünschen wir uns
auch ein gewisses Maß mehr an
Ehrlichkeit für den politischen Prozess
in Kiel heute Protest der Landwirte
gegen die Politik des Bundes von der
Agrarministerkonferenz fordern die
Bauern eine sichere Perspektive für die
heimische Landwirtschaft Bundesminister
mir hofft auf breite Unterstützung damit
mehr Tierschutz in den Stellen bezahlbar
wird man kann nicht sagen die Landwirte
sollen die Stelle umbauen das kostet
eine Menge Geld die müssen sich dafür
verschulden und es sollen sie aus dem
netto finanzieren das wird nicht gehen
also muss die Politik entscheiden auf
welchem Weg der Umbau der Stelle
finanziert werden soll damit die Bauern
da Verlässlichkeit haben mehr Platz für
die Tiere Bauer pritschau will umbauen
und fehlt im Augenblick der Mut diese
Schritt zu machen einmal ist das
wirklich ein großes Invest ca 2
Millionen und auf der anderen Seite
befürchten wir dass sich die Bedingung
in dieser Bauzeit noch wieder ändern
könnten so und er hofft auf eine
Einigung auf der Agrarministerkonferenz
damit der Planungssicherheit hat
[Musik]
Erfolg in der Schule hängt immer noch
sehr vom Elternhaus ab daher sollen
Schulen mit vielen sozial
benachteiligten Schülerinnen und
Schülern künftig mit zwei Milliarden
Euro pro Jahr unterstützt werden Bund
und Länder haben sich dazu auf erste
Eckpunkte verständigt so das
Bundesbildungsministerium 4000 Schulen
mit rund einer Million Schülern sollen
vom staatchancenprogramm profitieren
acht Monate so lang soll eine Klima
Demonstranten in Haft ohne Bewährung so
dass Urteil eines Berliner Amtsgerichts
laut der letzten Generation sei es die
härteste Strafe gegen ein Mitglied der
Gruppe die 41-Jährige hatte dreimal die
Straße blockiert und im Prozess
angekündigt weiter protestieren zu
wollen das Urteil ist noch nicht
rechtskräftig
ein klares Zeichen setzen die Liebe
segnen egal wer wen lebt das war das
Motto gestern in Köln vor dem Dom dort
hatten katholische Priester aus
verschiedenen Gemeinden eine
Segnungsfeier für gleichgeschlechtliche
paarezelebriert aus Protest gegen
Kardinal Rainer Maria Woelki der
unterstützt nämlich die ablehnende
Haltung des Vatikans gut 500 Menschen
feierten den Gottesdienst mit den Paaren
im Zeichen der Regenbogenflagge
[Musik]
und jetzt können wir zum Sport der erste
Spieltag in der Champions League ist
vorbei und ja es gab Licht und Schatten
bei den deutschen Clubs sind und vor
allem für Union Berlin war es ein ganz
besonderer Abend die Bühne der Champions
League ausgerechnet beim Rekordsieger
Real Madrid die eisernen machten ein
großes Spiel hielten lange das 0:0 und
mussten doch eine spätere Niederlage
hinnehmen
93 Minuten und 20 Sekunden hält Union
Berlin in den dunklen Trikots mit Glück
das 0:0 dann kommt der Pech Moment und
Jude Bellingham macht den Siegtreffer
für Real Madrid Amazon Tor bekommst nach
so einem Aufwand den du betreibst dann
ist es einfach nur mega enttäuschend
weil ich glaube den historischen Tag für
für Union in hätten wir uns unfassbar
gerne mit dem Unentschieden versüßt sie
hätten sicherlich sehr gerne den Punkt
mitgenommen
aber ich glaube dass wir am Ende des
Spielern schon verlinken den ersten
Auftritt in der Champions League erlebt
Union meist in der Abwehr zweimal ist
der Ball am Pfosten den Rest klärts
Tormann Frederick Reno eine Handvoll
Minuten fehlt um den Punkt mit nach
Hause zu nehmen wenn man das dann nicht
tut und dann so ein blödes Gegentor
bekommt dann dann ist einfach
unglaublich traurig deswegen bin ich ein
bisschen sauer gerade auf dem Fußball
und gleichzeitig liebe ich ihn über
alles jetzt muss Union gegen Neapel und
Prager versuchen zu punkten
[Applaus]
mit einem 4:3 Sieg gegen Manchester
United startete der FC Bayern in die
Champions League alle sieben Tore und
die Highlights zu den übrigen Partien
gibt es auf heute.de und in der heute
App
im ersten Spiel nach dem WM Debakel
trifft die deutsche Frauen
Nationalmannschaft morgen auf Dänemark
in der neu eingeführten nations League
geht es für das Team um Kapitän in
Alexandra Popp um die Qualifikation für
die Olympischen Spiele in Paris
im wichtigen Auftaktspiel in vibor wird
Co-Trainerin Britta Carlson die
erkrankte Bundestrainerin Martina Voss
Tecklenburg vertreten die Mission
verlorenes Renommee zurückgewinnen die
Spielerinnen sind auch selbst gefordert
das wissen sie auch wir haben von außen
den Rahmen gegeben als Trainer und
Trainerin und sie selbst haben wir auch
in der Reflexion gesagt wir müssen
selbst Verantwortung übernehmen auch in
dem Bewusstsein dass vielleicht nicht
alles von Anfang an klappt der Umgang
mit Rückschlägen ein Kritikpunkt nach
der WM das Team nun fokussiert auf die
neue Aufgabe jeder einzelne Spielerin
will nächstes Jahr durch Frankreich
reisen um um dafür Olympia und für die
Goldmedaille wieder spielen zu können
aus Europa qualifizieren sich nur die
beiden besten Teams der nations League
für Olympia plus gastgeber Frankreich
und das war's vom Sport Jana danke schön
in den nächsten Stunden wird es Gewitter
geben das Wetter für morgen erfahren Sie
gleich von Herrli Dunja Hayali begrüßt
sie um 21:45 Uhr zum heute journal
machen sie es gut
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter heute gab es ein
fast durchgehendes Regenband von
Norwegen bis nach Spanien das ist dieser
Kaltfront geschuldet die uns jetzt
erreicht und den Regen bringt und in den
nächsten Stunden für teils kräftige
Gewitter sorgen wird und wir sehen auf
dem Atlantik hier diese
streuselkuchenartige Bewirkung das ist
die Kaltluft die für die Abkühlung
sorgen wird in der Nacht bzw in den
nächsten Stunden hier Schauer und
Gewitter die allmählich ostwärts ziehen
und sie sehen das zieht dann
größtenteils im Tagesverlauf dann ab im
Süden regnet es dafür länger von Westen
her kommen neue Schauer und Gewitter
rein und in den nächsten Stunden also
diese Gewitter die sich ostwärts
verlagern können auch am Anfang der
Nacht noch relativ kräftig sein bei
Temperaturen von 16 bis 17 Grad im Osten
und 9 Grad ganz im Westen morgen gibt's
noch Schauer im Osten ziehen ab im Süden
regnet es weiter sonst gibt es Schauer
und Gewitter die reinziehen dazwischen
auch sonniger Abschnitte mit höchsten
Werten bis 22 Grad im Südwesten und 13
Grad an den Alpen und die nächsten Tage
am Samstag noch einige Schauer es wird
aber schon freundlicher und vor allem am
Montag bis 24 Grad ein schöner Abend